Transcriber: Bardise ELDeeb
المدقّق: Muhammad Samir
مرحبا. كيف حالكم؟ اليوم أريد التحدث عن
مواجهة المخاوف
ذهبت في مرة إلى الحديقة
لعبت لعبة أسمها "قضبان القرد"
وسقطت وجُرح رأسي. تألمت كثيرًا, ونزفت
الكثير من الدم وخاطوا لي الكثير من القطب
لكن تحسنت حالتي وتحسنت الأمور
وعدت وذهبت إلى الحديقة ذاتها
ولعبت باللعبة ذاتها,
ووقعت وكسرت يدي
ووضعت الجبيرة لمدة ثلاثة أسابيع
وحُرمت من لعب كرة السلة
وحُرمت من السباحة
حُرمت من كرة القدم
حُرمت من أشياء كثيرة
كنت أذهب إلى الحديقة وأتأمل اللعبة
وكنت أود أن ألعبها مرة أخرى
ولكن كنت أشعر بالخوف
وأتذكر الوقت الذي كسرت فيه يدي
وجُرح رأسي
لكن في مرة من المرات
ذهبت إلى الحديقة
ونظرت إلى اللعبة بشجاعة وعزم
(تصفيق)
تحديت نفسي, واستجمعت قواي
وتمكنت من إنهاء اللعبة
(تصفيق)
وكنت سعيدًا جدًا
وأريد من كل من يسمعني أن يكسر حاجز الخوف
عنده ويحوله إلى صديق, وشكرًا!
وأريد أن أهديكم هذا المقطع
دعونا نشاهد مقطع كريم أولاً
أبقى معي